now we're going to take this idea here
this particular one we just did this is
multiplication idea right and I promised
on tuesday that would move into division
which is not that hard right like you
can multiply you can divine it stands to
reason if you can do one you can do the
other but it is actually trickier okay
so make a new sub heading for me right
which is multiplication and division
thinking about multiplication and
division and before we get into the the
algorithms the process we want to
understand what we're actually doing now
I've said this many times I hope it's
starting to sink in right the classic
mathematician strategy when attacking a
hard problem is to think about a similar
problem that's easier and try and take
some of those lessons and apply them to
the harder problem okay because
sometimes a hard problem is just
overwhelming by just looking at it like
that idea what it started right but if
you can take on which is smaller to add
it a little bit and you can make some
progress then you can apply that
progress to your trickier one so
multiplication and division way before
we met polynomials right we will
multiply and divide it just regular
numbers okay so example let's think that
something like yes we can multiply these
numbers right seven times forty-three
now I'm deliberately asking us to do
this one by hand even though your
calculator can do it because even though
your calculator can do this your
calculator cannot do this it can't take
this algebra if you let that those x is
equal to numbers and i'll show you how
to import numbers into your calculator
as variables it'll do that quite happily
but the algebra itself is something your
scientific calculator camera it's not
equipped to do okay so therefore i want
to do this by hand said when we get to
polynomials you'll be okay how do i do
this by here okay I'll first do I'll do
my unit strength so here three times 7
which is 21 okay and then i do my tens
so because it's tens i put a zero there
and then i go four times 7 which is 20
28 right okay what i do with those
numbers i add them very good because
I've done this altercation done that
multiplication I don't need to multiply
anymore
or and you get an answer out ok now this
process of mummification is exactly
mirrored by the process of division I
can take this number down the bottom and
I know it must be a multiple of seven
yeah because that's how I got the number
right so let's just quickly rehearse
this if I have 301 and I want to divide
it by seven what do i do like how do I
actually yeah you look at the first
numbers when you see if I can go into
fantastic so I look at the very first
number is three days on can I can I get
any sense out of three and the answer is
no so you go to the next one 30 can I
get any sevens out of that and the
answer is yes I can i get four of them
you say for up here what do you do with
that for i'm going to write another
below 30 but the number i'm going to
write is not four but four sevens right
like that's how much of that 30 gets
taken out 10 / 07 for my seven crosses
28 right so what do I do with this 28 i
subtract ok so I say 30 take away 28 is
to write and then I repeat I say well
how many sevens can I get out of to
enter nine so then I go to the next
number that's why I go to the next
number it's not just because like it's
because I want what I do it's because I
can't get anymore 17 so you write the 21
down and you say how many sevens can I
get now and the answer is 3 which is
rather a relief okay because that's
that's what we started with I'm not
quite finished yet though I'm not quite
for you to what I normally do at this
stage remember I went four by seven
gives me 28 so not now at this stage I
will usually go 3 by 7 gives me 21 and
there's a zero here but that's your
about the 0 is important it's the
remainder very good it's what what's
left over when I divine but there isn't
a remainder for this right because it
evenly divides does that make sense okay
really quickly now do you remember okay
multi-mission division how they work
let's just do another one and we'll just
go straight to the division because
that's what I'm focusing on
multiplication of polynomials fine okay
but division let's try let's try
something
this great let's give this a speed okay
what do I do papito so there's a 50 good
50 which is visible a good hold on hold
on hold on not to this I think what you
mean is I can guy can get a tailor it's
big enough that and get it out of it
right because 50 is not divisible by
eight okay and then what I do okay Helen
I can get six because 6 times 8 is 48
and then I try to do anymore so when i
say i can get six of them i multiply
down and what I do with this 48 i
subtract Here I am what I do with that
guy I can't I can't get any eight out of
two so that's why I appeal to the next
number right and then how many eggs can
I get out of that I can get two of them
right I get to 2 times 8 gives me 16 and
what I do with that that's the remainder
okay so i'm going to write that blog
here okay happy with that now what this
means is let's just step back for a
second this process here of division
means seven times forty-three is 301
like that's that's these numbers
connected here okay that's what I've got
over here when I've got a remainder what
does this mean it's it's ever so
slightly different it's these four
numbers they were all connected right I
can say 503 is equal to what's equal to
on the basis of all these numbers up
here i can write it as a fraction if i
if i divide here but actually i think
about 503 the whole number just like I
think of a polynomial is a whole pollen
seven times forty-three equals 301
that's the multiplication sentence that
goes with this okay I you can think
about is in versus right you've got
multiplication as a function you got
division as its inverse okay so this
time I can say 503 the inverse of this
is going to be 8 x 62 but there's a
rabbi now you're not that guy are you
happy with that so i get this statement
ok this is the vision statement out of
this process of long division ok long
division he's me a statement that
connects all of these numbers together
so you have a mercenary that's exactly
right and in fact you can go ahead you
can checking the cargo or what's 8 x 62
plus 7 ok i'm guessing 8 x 62 is 419 Oh
see wait 668 496 because we're that good
at multiplication right no probably good
subtraction but there you go that's the
idea ok now to vision with numbers long
division with numbers where are ok with
this we're comfortable with this but
we're in the polynomial way ok so how do
we do this